tiktok soll sich negativ auf die
Konzentrationsfähigkeit und die
psychische Gesundheit auswirken sogar
eine richtige sucht sein aber was ist
dran an diesen Behauptungen zunächst
einmal gibt es tiktok noch nicht lange
genug für umfassende Studien aber es
gibt Erkenntnisse über die negativen
Auswirkungen von Social Media im
allgemeinen Benachrichtigungen zum
Beispiel können uns ablenken und die
ständige Erwartung weiterer Mitteilungen
belastet unsere Konzentrationsfähigkeit
was die psychische Gesundheit betrifft
gibt es gemischte Ergebnisse hier kommt
es darauf an wer Social Media wie nutzt
und auf Social Media wirklich süchtig
macht das ist umstritten fakt ist aber
dass euch tiktok mit einem
psychologischen Trick auf der Plattform
hält welcher das ist das erfahrt ihr in
unserem längeren Video zu dem Thema da
gehen wir auch in die Tiefe und zeigen
euch warum so manche Behauptungen
totaler Bullshit ist und was wir auch
überprüfen ist die Aussage